Loki calls back the joke from Avengers
he's my brother adopted
it's my brother he killed 80 people in
two days
he's adopted and Thor meets cork voiced
and performed by taikuy TT along with
Meek now Korg is a Cronin one of whom
Thor wrecked in the dark world and two
others the guardian Zip by in volume two
you don't need to be afraid unless
you're made of scissors just a little
rock paper says a joke for you now later
Korg says that he stepped on Meek who
has scissor arms Rock beat scissors and
this joke extends back to when Drax said
about the sakarins I think of shikaran
as paper people so paper imprisons rock
Korg introduces us to Doug Doug his Doug
Doug is purple with green clothes
matching Thor's street clothes earlier
and they're both inverses of Hulk's
purple on green color scheme
[Music]